so als ob gezielter gibt kitz und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft heute spielen wir auf timo one
world one 55 gehalten ich bin doktor
bändern von dem kanal www.youtube.com
okay leute wir reden gar nicht groß drum
rum wir springen direkt mit einem rennen
kind in die erste runde ist okay ersten
runde einige der aufnahme wenn das
direkt meine shadow case ich habe gesagt
ich habe als kind drin was das nichts
drin natürlich nicht das war ja auch du
also ich brillen dafür bist du stellst
aus counters also gerade die das nicht
wissen es und ist heute firstfive ist
dass das format in dem es darum geht wer
zuerst fünf mit gegen andere hat dann
einfach so scheiße pvp ich bin wirklich
stolz was richtig laut
die erste runde dann einzelne für mich
runde nummer 22 und es ist einfach
wahrscheinlich ist ein super king super
jetzt allererst ist deaktiviert
sie kriegt ob instant alter.de ein neuer
gehweg trotten ins der junge ist in
sukow war ich will das noch mal machen
aktivieren das jetzt kommt ok 22 für
mich kundennummer schreien vielleicht
noch mit dem gleichen kit es geht
nochmal und jetzt hast du super
aktiviert das man auf gar nicht da bist
du wirst du beobachtest zurück du bist
unsichtbar und sichtbar bei mir wie du
lügst naja du holen du warst du hund
alter du hast nicht zum beispiel auf
alles junge alter wer einmal lügt
dreister [ __ ]
ich habe nur angst dass ich mein schwert
quickdrop beweist man kann es glauben
zumindest die richtigen schillers tod
mit der maus dafür dass jemand der junge
koch schon deutschland konstant juni
älter du kannst du echt gut nein
überhaupt nicht
das einfach noch schlecht als ich das
für leute denn wird komplett zerstört 13
uhr schenkt man jetzt ganz klar deine
hotkeys umgelegt oder nein ich habe
einfach gab mit der maus wobei ich hab
das einzige hodgkin war das jetzt noch
mal gesehen habe dass ein super auf der
drei war habe ich einmal auf die drei
geholt geht sonst dagegen habe ich
verloren ich bin jetzt so was daran lag
es hat einfach markiert recht von
scheiße 13 mal gucken ob in der nächsten
runde auf scheiße ist eine nummer die
oro das kind ist richtig random junge
mann das kind ist richtig wenn die leute
herzlich willkommen zur unternehmer 4
what the [ __ ] them speed junge diese
zone wird so random ich wünsche euch
viel spaß soll name ist donald duck erst
mal eine richtige frankfurter kongress
soll was sie gerne ändern bälle genutzt
um zwei meter zu geben
die nase juckt und fans bietet weg ich
war ganz so laut dass mir ein hit geben
es nicht mehr dauern gewesen instant den
straßen ist ein spannender machen
als ob das als erste x verplant oder
bist du einfach ihr wollt spannend
machen ich für 13
die junge doch leise war mit einer
nonstop zum mit heimann wirklich so übel
zeitnah minuten
wenn es aber so unprofessionell wisst
ihr normalerweise sagen wie du behalten
wenn sie wieder gemeinde youtube man die
sachen machen einfach so dass man es dem
feld nicht im video sagt jetzt will ich
zu gesperrt du du du du du du hast wie
hey sagt er
jetzt habe ich keine ranger männer der
frankfurter ping ist ja gar nicht so
wirksam habe meine nase dass das so eine
qual ich leide ich leide ich leide ich
leide alter meine nase juckt ok drei zu
eins gegen nummer drei wäre mir power
bogen statt 123 und einen ziemlich
schlechten gegner da drüben gerade bist
unsichtbar ja plötzlich steht da vor mir
wird alles ja das ist das zählt nur das
zählt
ich stelle haben ab jetzt nicht neben
mir steht und ich sehe ihn ist dahin
laufen sollte das für einen bug schreibt
meine kommentare erzählt dass oder nicht
je
wir werden mal so spielen als würde es
nicht zählen wenn so leute die nächste
runde lustigerweise haben einfach
komplett rente dich bewegst du und ich
komme für die ich würd ich komme für
dich wäre alles ist der deutsch fucking
german locker sieht er mich nicht
einfach er sieht man jetzt sehe ich
durch aber als antrieb ist man kurz ja
klar wenn die wir wieder stolz kann aber
sagen dass mich gesehen hast wie a ha
ich sehe dich nicht wo bist du nein
gemeint das ist gemein dass fünfmal
daneben geschlagen so dass ich voll
kassenschlange jetzt der ausbau jetzt
vielleicht der box bei mir an dieser
stelle der muskel den praktischen jahr
nicht schlecht nicht schlecht die
schlechtigkeit ihr getan oder
durchforstet ausmachen für die nächste
runde vier zu eins für mich stets schon
in die nächste
leute das letzte vielleicht jetzt geht
das heutigen tage ist wieder richtig
geld
was ist das für ein fucking random kit
als ob kommt schon hier bau und die aims
heißt aus dem rad ist beim junge was wir
ende misst dieses kit ich sehe nur deine
partikeln rechtzeitig wieder unsicher
bleibe ich dich wieder und wie gut du
bist immer mal von kurz nicht ich bin
kurz 62 zu viele leute irgendwas kann
sich seines das ist die richtige redet
die ganze zeit nur darüber dass er
einfach nicht nichts mehr ich nehme das
ganz zufällig das kit von jemandem bei
dem ich weiß dass er okay leute letzte
runde des tages vielleicht ist es wieder
ein matchball für mich quasi nur dass
hier keine bonds gibt in diesem spiel
außerdem außerdem eine haltemarke
partikel denn ich war ja nehmen am
anfang kurz an die redaktionen aus dann
geht's dann wieder ein kurzvideo mein
name ist cool sind okay so bleibt dafür
ist ganz einfach denn welches auto fest
eigentlich der doktor bmw dafür ist er
bekannt
so krasse hits man dazu muss man sagen
dass ben einfach in frankfurt sitzt
jetzt gerade das heißt direkt und gibst
mir die heftigsten hit jedem server
netzwerk das es irgendwie gibt auf der
ganzen welt und ich jetzt einfach in
berlin
hier war es gibt hier dönerläden für
zwei euro uns aber nicht viel von ihr
und jetzt gibt natürlich die hitze der
junge 42 stets wenn jetzt darum gehst du
alt quickborn 08 hier drauf wie macht
man das ich kann überhaupt nicht sucht
man immer weg die performance hier
gerade ist so erwerben
die leute trotzdem ist das bittere alles
super die jetzt gerade da hacker
der maler selbst suchten dort sich
darauf meinem freund als ob leipzig
volkert junge dass dort kinder
mitgebracht doch da war ich habe meiner
maus zu langsam scheiße okay leute es
steht wieder die nötige mich noch mehr
mit dem rad
alle drei und ich will noch mal
trainiert auswege irgendwie plätze und
jetzt wirklich mal die letzte muster
verpacken kommen okay vielleicht letzte
runde in fernsehshows apples marketing
timur bakan schrank nennen das video
doch unsichtbar auf timo die abag
unbesiegbarkeit sci tech so leute ja das
gab das video und nahmen sich auf die
mobilitec gesehen herzlich willkommen
hat richtig klick wir aber die ganze
zeit wartet mit kommt es aber zu tun
in winden gläubiger bleibt schwach
angefangen muss gehen ich sehe es hat
einfach mehr leute sind man erkennt dass
der cup strategie jetzt geht der kampf
so als ob da gibt's viel trank ja gibt
als ob hat eine maut als eine woche hat
keine schmerzen du aus alter habe ich
weiter gefestigt wurde das junge bitte
alter 4 zu 1 aufgeholt so am ende aber
das ist für mich viel besser kann es so
pilling an
ich weiß es nicht aber werden nochmal
locker nicht damit kurz noch mal
eine angel drin also wir kommen und weil
wir eine anhalterin haben kein benzin
wenn ich mir so scheiße defensivspiel
wir die ganze zeit lasse ich mir richtig
scheiße und gar nichts gibt es
offensichtlich zu
die tde de tir na ja ich noch gesagt
deine schnauze fällt deine schnauze alte
als ob das war ja wohl war die
aufholjagd
junge komm schon ich habe aber auch gut
gesucht
also ich bin drei wochen geht das noch
also da ist meine hobbys gelten aus ich
habe null gehortet okay das waren meine
ersten folge man das ärgert mich dass
ich verloren habe aber guck mal hier
hier ist ein stift der aussieht wie eine
blume um eure moral zu heben ich haben
gewinnen lassen
so jetzt leute wir sehen uns bei der
nächsten folge wieder dreimal